i'm truly thankful welcome back vince
carter please turn your attention to the
video board
as we present a tribute to your amazing
career
and give you the final goodbye you
rightfully deserve
it's official insanity comes to an end
carter announced on twitter i'm
officially done playing basketball
professionally
vince carter has been one of the great
players in nba history
first ballot hall of famer one of the
greatest ever do it eight-time all-star
two-time all-nba
well over 25 000 career points half man
half amazing carter is invincible
man vince
you can't sanity it any better than that
you know as a toronto raptors coach i
still have people
all the time come up to me and say oh
toronto raptors and the next thing they
say is vince carter
vince put toronto in canadian basketball
on the map
he really impacted the nation and the
city there
carter's going to get a shot off vince
carter wins the game he has like over 20
years of
great memories toronto playing with
tracy mcgrady mcgrady putting on a
little showtime
vince carter any of the windmill lives
i'm a sucker for windmill
that's what log came to say my favorite
vince carter moment is two thousand duck
contest it's a dunk contest he's just
blew everybody away here is vince connor
my favorite defense card is done in that
dunk contest was the super fly the 360
windmill that dunk is already hard but
he did it with ease he turned this way
instead of turning it this way his first
dump
he won the del contest
my favorite moment was uh the honey dip
elbow arm in the rim that's my favorite
dunk for a long time
my favorite dunk probably the when he
bounced it in between the legs i didn't
know what i saw
when he did it i remember him telling me
he said he never uh he never practiced
on before
oh my goodness gracious that's it show's
over
every kid was doing that it was like
it's over it's over yeah that's
something i definitely remember
with a spectacular show one of the most
talked about all-star weekend moments of
all time he set the bar for all
done content he definitely brought back
to nasa to the dunk contest
[Applause]
vince carter major elevation
definitely number one for me probably
the best knocker ever is number one on
my list vince is number one
42 year old vince carter the first band
to play
in the nba in four different decades
this carter's been a transcendent player
he did everything with class a great
example for any young player
more seasons in the nba than any other
player ever he's been the face of the
franchise and he's also been a role
player
playing four decades is a ridiculous
feat
he came in as a high flyer develop his
perimeter skills the fact that he was
able to adjust
and still be effective for whatever team
he was playing for shows that
you know he was very dedicated to the
game carter
42 connects a back down
look at this obviously he's half man
half amazing he's a special athlete one
that we've never really seen before
future hall of famer sergeant vincent
lamar i just want to thank you
thank you thank you for all you did for
the game thank you for the impact you
had on the league
thank you vince carter for all the
moments thank you for
being a great teammate congratulations
on a
long long
long career your game spoke for yourself
man you made me imagine that
anything was possible i hope every time
you you watch me play
from here on out that you see a little
piece of you and me
you are not just half man half amazing
but a 100 heart vince carter hearing it
from the holy grail
[Applause]
vince carter amazing career that he's
had
we have gotten the marble at one vince
carter you were truly one of the goats
of this game
love you brother congratulations you
deserve it man
and enjoy retirement love